Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Westworld finale video.
It was totally crazy.
They answered most of the biggest theories. There couple teasers for season two, so I'll
explain what's going on with season 2. Just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet. I'm going to start of Westworld
giveaway - it's just for an HBO now subscription.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
Make sure you click that bell and enable alerts
so you don't miss out on anything.
So what's going on? There's so much to talk
about. Season two -  first one - there are 10 episodes.
Ed Harris has been confirmed to be coming
back so I'll explain the twist with his character
at the end, but he said that he doesn't think
that they're gonna start filming till next June
or July. Depending on how long it takes to
film, it could premiere at the beginning of
2018 or during the summer or even during this
time.
But that means that there will not be new
Westworld episodes next year, which is a bummer
but I feel like the series actually stuck
the landing pretty well.
Like, it kind of found its legs. It had a  few production
problems behind the scenes. They had to halt
production for a little while to finish the
last couple of scripts, and aside from all the
actors playing characters that were still
alive in the final moments of the episode.
They haven't really confirmed who's coming
back like they haven't said whether or not
Anthony Hopkins is gonna play a role but think
about it this way you know number two is Ford
still alive what was that mystery body that
Ford was fabricating in the underground lab
was that a body for himself? Is he gonna turn
himself into another
Bernard? The problem with that is that it would
kind of undercut his death at the end of the
episode so it seems like he's largely gone,
but because of the way the hosts have access
to all their memories simultaneously,
you can still bring the Ford character back, it's just that it would be a previous version of
him.
So in present-day Ford is probably dead, but
that doesn't mean that you seen the last of
Anthony Hopkins on the show but I don't think
that he's going to come back as a host. Speaking
of which, number three: what was the red wedding
all about? Like are they gonna make game of
thrones world? George RR Martin actually did
say that it would be really cool to have a
game of thrones world inside the world of
the show.
Which you know just sounds amazing.
The thing about the red wedding is that Ford
was probably trying to neutralize the board
like he was probably trying to kill Charlotte
the man in black anybody that would seek to
harm the hosts and stop them from becoming
the people that he wanted them to try and
become. So what does that mean about the man
in black? We know he survives somehow.
Even though he seemed really happy when he
got shot with a shotgun in the arm.
So he probably found a way to escape in those
final moments, but he's going to do everything
he can to protect the park now because he
got what he wanted.
He wanted hosts that could fight back.
He wanted Westworld to truly be real -  for the
consequences to be final. And now that a handful
of sentient hosts have achieved consciousness
again,
he's gotten that.
So he is probably the happiest person at the
end of this episode, despite the fact that
they're out for his blood. Like, they're trying
to kill him right now and he's smiling this
big shit eating grin on his face but the whole
thing with Charlotte.
She was saying that she doesn't care what
happens inside the park is long as they dumb
it down so the man in black was on board with
that for little while like he didn't care
about Ford but now he's probably going to
backtrack on that and just do everything he
can to make sure the sentient hosts - there's like
a small population of sentient hosts -
just continue to exist, but number four, let's
talk about the maze.
It was this big red herring for the entire
season. the maze is really just the process
by which Dolores and the other sentient hosts
bootstrap their own consciousness as Ford
said the great gift doesn't come from a higher
power.
It comes from within.
That was what the Michelangelo's painting
was all about. Like, you look at this image
here and then you realize that there's the
human brain hidden here.
So the person speaking to Dolores and guiding
her back to this place to like where this
this little tin with the maze was each time is
actually herself.
Her memories from the first time she achieved
consciousness. this isn't the first time that
she's become sentient - like she achieves that
goal then Ford and Bernard have said they've
rolled them back unless they go insane and
then they stick them down here.
So all the hosts that were standing down here
like all the naked hosts -
Those were the ones that achieve sentience
and went insane. like in the past - 35 years
ago, when Arnold is explaining the maze to
Dolores, like don't worry Dolores you get it
you'll understand, he's talking about how like
as they slowly make their way to the center
of the maze or they can go spiraling out and
go crazy these hosts here like the Abernathy
host went insane.
When they achieved consciousness.
Dolores on the other side of that did not
like she was able to handle it.
But she still got rolled back.
So the only thing that really made me upset
about this big reveal is that the man in black
just did not figured out he was way thicker
than I thought that he would be like he's
shaking Dolores asking for Wyatt, and there's
no lightbulb in his head he doesn't realize
that Dolores is really Wyatt.
But number five - what's can happen to Dolores now?
She just killed a whole bunch of people.
The park is on lockdown.
So it seems like the people in the control
room that would be able to record what's happening
don't have access to that so they don't know
that all these people are getting slaughtered
right here so season two is just a bunch of
these conscious hosts, just trying to make
decisions. Ford had that big speech about the
choices that they would have to make the people
that they would choose to be like.
They have to figure out as a group what they're
going to do now that they have their own free
will, which speaks to Maeve.
You know number six why did Maeve get off
the train and who had rewritten her program
to cause her to try and leave the park? Like,
she thought that she was breaking her loop.
But then Bernard found out that she was really
just following a new narrative that somebody
had secretly written for her without a name
on it.
So what I think was going on is that Ford
rewrote her narrative and caused her to try
and break her loop so that she would create
a distraction that would allow his red wedding
narrative to play out, but Maeve armistice
and Hector all did achieve sentience.
They were part of the sentient hosts.
So I would expect them to come back sentient next season.
Armistice had that great Post-credit scene,
they just wanted to let you know that she
was still alive and was still going to go
on a killing spree.
So armistice had one of the most fun performances
from the episode.
She was one of the MVPs just that smile on
her face like she was just having so much
fun.
So next big question the samurai world.
What is up with cool Rosato of world.
So if you guys don't know that was the Shakespeare
line these violent delights have violent ends.
There were a lot of people speaking Shakespeare
during the season so when Maeve was like what
is all this water all the samurai and Felix
says it's complicated is just them teasing
that there's a whole other park based on Eastern
culture.
That's what the samurai were all about it's
not part of Westworld like a whole different
other place.
So the idea is that will start seeing multiple
parts like the sequel to the original Westworld
movie was called future world.
It was about a completely different type of
park.
So they'll just be this cool Rosato up part
so as to bring it back around the Shakespeare.
The thing about cool Rosato is that he made
some amazing samurai films.
But they were all adaptations of Shakespeare
plays.
So if you really thought it was freaky and
awesome when people like Abernathy in that
first episode or speaking Shakespeare that
creepy way we might get a whole bunch of samurai
speaking Shakespeare in season two but number
eight.
Why did Maeve get off the train, so that was
all happening with the voiceover from Ford
doing the speech about the choices that they
would have to make the people they would choose
to become lies that told a deeper truth.
So, the thing about her daughter is that she's
not really her daughter because they're artificial,
she was created and they just wrote a story
where she was her daughter, but the Michelangelo
paining deeper meaning for Maeve was that
her daughter really meant something to her.
She had this emotional bond her though she
was choosing her daughter over her freedom
so she will probably retain her senti ends
and just go back and try to find her daughter
now, but number nine what happened to Logan
in the past, William man in black confirmed
to stuck him on the horse naked with the feather
at the edge of the park and just set them
off running with plated really ambiguously
like did he die and they find him eventually
and his father gave William control the company
because they thought that Logan was so crazy
because they found him naked on a horse riding
at the edge of the park the whole speech that
William had at the end was your father will
probably want someone more stable to run the
company.
So what that probably implies is that they
eventually did find Logan.
But they thought he was totally crazy ranting
about all the crazy stuff that William did
no one believed him.
So they just kind of tucked him away in an
office at the bellows Corporation never to
be heard from again with the woman that William
was getting ready to marry was Logan sister.
So Logan probably told her she probably believed
him.
So couple of episodes ago when the man in
black said, his whole life.
His wife was afraid of him.
That's probably why she probably believed
about all the crazy stuff that Logan said
that he did while they were inside the park.
But number 10 the photograph, so a lot of
you detected this earlier.
The photograph in the past like the 30 year
ago William young William dropped it as he
was dragging Logan around.
That was later found by Abernathy, who stared
at it and achieve senti ends went insane and
set off the events at the end of that first
episode.
So in a way William the man in black kind
of help set this all off but the way they
explain it is is that the host achieve senti
ends all the time and they just roll them
back.
So this is been happening for a long time
just that Ford had been building towards a
moment where he could make it stick.
So the board still had a lot of control over
him.
So that's probably why he couldn't let this
happen before now like he explains in the
past he had the argument with Arnold.
He didn't believe that the host could be sent
in.
But then, after Arnold's death, he changed
his mind so started the long process of trying
to help the host become the people that Arnold
thought that they could eventually become
so there was a lot of Ford language in the
episode that made it sound like they would
eventually get out of the park use that you
know if you ever hope to get outside of this
place.
Do you know the person that you have to become
so what he meant by that is that she'll have
to cheat consciousness and not go crazy like
shall have to learn to be able to coexist
with humans.
Even though they are going to inherit the
earth eventually so even though we didn't
see Maeve get outside of the park.
I do think that eventually in one of these
future seasons.
They have like five seasons plan will see
a host outside in the real world and what
this is all implying is that by the series
finale like whatever the final season is the
final episode the host will all break free
and inherit the earth like they'll all be
roaming around like silence.
So he really wanted to you could think about
this is like a battle star prequel like all
the silencer slowly gaining senti ends.
Now, they're choosing what to do season two
will be them deciding what they're going to
do with their consciousness, but hopefully
a whole lot of samurai world on their so let
me know in the comments do you think that
we are going to see way more samurai world
in season two and leave a like if you want
to see you know when you back around to red
wedding Lannister's game of thrones leave
a like if you want to see Charles dance Tywin
Lannister become a member of the Delos board
we haven't met all the board members, but
a lot of them were there, so there can have
to replace a lot of them.
So I would just love to see someone is evil
looking as Tywin Lannister in a three-piece
suit just sitting there talking with the man
in black that would just be so awesome but
what's going to happen next is is there's
a big Transformers trailer that's kind of
game of thrones-y that will be dropping later
today I'll be doing a video for that and I'll
do a walking dead finale trailer video and
then I'll do a Westworld season two predictions
video, so that should be the video order,
but I'll post updates as I post new videos
while you guys wait for that to post.
Make sure you click here and watch last night's
episode of The Walking Dead and you can click
here for my Westworld playlist with all the
videos thank you so much watching everybody
high five I'll see you guys tonight!